so i had graduated college i had gotten
my degree i had done everything society
told me to do i worked for aon hewitt at
the time you know a huge you know
insurance company
and um
i had done everything society told me to
do but like in my heart of hearts i
didn't feel like i because i didn't feel
like i was like a real man i felt like i
hadn't challenged myself you know you
know back in the day they used to do the
right of passage cultures yeah it's
called the bar mitzvah yeah right
exactly
so
you know multiple things you know like
yeah like you know some like indians
they would take the boy and be like all
right here's a spear you gotta go kill a
lion exactly
and you gotta bring the the wolf's skin
back and you're gonna get a wife you're
gonna get a house and you're gonna walk
on fire and stuff like that yeah and
then they have they have a ceremony like
okay he is now a man he's got a wife so
i had just felt like this kind of
masculine emptiness inside me i just
feel like that could do something more
and so i was like you know i am going to
make my own right a passage i said i'm
going to go to japan
i'm going to go by myself why japan just
because it was far away and bottom line
is this like at that time i was hanging
out people who
you know show me friends i'll show your
future and at that time all my friends
did just call duty smoking weed
jerking off the porn all the amazing
things right you know stuff that will
destroy you yeah
stuff that will destroy you as a man and
i said if i hang out with these guys i'm
going to be like them god bless them
we're all the lords people but i don't
want to be like them i want to be i want
to live the [ __ ] hot dude life man i
want to have money i want to have status
i want to have girls i want to be happy
and fulfilled because i believe we only
live one time
and so
i
nuked everything in america i
i burned the ships i nuked my credit i i
got rid of my i had a toyota tacoma that
was like at least right and i called him
up i was like listen dude i'm sorry guys
i'm not gonna be able to make the
payments on this oh shoot i said the
truck is in this parking lot here and i
put the keys in the visor i'm getting
you just left the truck oh my god i left
it and i called him and i was just like
i'm so sorry you know
um i got rid of my apartment i sold
everything i put an ad on craigslist
like everything in my apartment is free
oh wow this
hillbillies came out how did you feel
about that though because i went through
the same thing as he did i burned my
ships literally like hardcore so when i
i did that i bought a one-way ticket to
tokyo i had 2500 in my pocket
november 4th 2012 and i got off the
plane in tokyo and i've never been to
japan before nevermind you have never
even vacationed there never like i'm
just moving to japan tokyo so i had a
giant i had a job lined up and i got off
the plane and the first thing i did was
like i have royally [ __ ] up oh god i
was like you just second guess yourself
oh i know that feeling i got off of the
plane i was like
everyone's asian i can't read [ __ ] i'm
alone by the way take off your glasses
right now people might think you're
asian you're just
no i'm not asian at all you're you're
mixed what are you my mom is from
trinidad and tobago and my dad he was
white trinion white you can keep them on
you're looking cool brother i don't you
know uh
i had a rough night
no no i was out with my buddy paul from
apex mindset and he's an animal i'm an
animal i ran into ferrari we were
driving all night and stuff not drinking
and driving we were driving
then drinking listen you're pulling over
and taking sips no i wasn't i'm dead ass
i don't i don't i don't know we were all
good we were speeding
and then i'm not the cops bro
and then we drink one is you look good
today but last night you were feeling
rough yeah i know this morning i was
feeling like okay this morning but
anyway back to japan right you're there
you're at the airport you're like what
the [ __ ] did i just do no pharrell's
like i was like dude jonathan you ran
your [ __ ] mouth and now look at this
[ __ ] you gotta fix this bro
so i was really really uh the first
three months pretty hard because you
know and there was no going back at that
point hell ruined your credit you sold
all your [ __ ] you told your friends go
[ __ ] themselves yeah you threw your call
of duty games in the garbage boom we out
yeah and and no for me i had dude i made
this say i did the exact same thing
really i had too much pride as a man to
go home i was like i can't go home i was
like i have got to figure this [ __ ] out
of course and
best decision in my life man within you
know within six months i had like my
main english teaching job honda had
picked me up this was 2012 and they're
paying me 80 an hour to teach them
english yeah in like their honda honda
yeah and they're they have a motorcycle
engineering department in saitama and i
worked with the engineers there tom
business english
and um and then i started doing a little
bit of modeling over there too you know
because like just because you're a
foreigner and like they always need
foreigners for like wedding gigs because
it's like cool to see
more thong but no no no
no monica's getting ideas in her that's
not my only fans
make sure you
yeah your comfort zone will kill you yes
you are not in your comfort zone no dude
you're in the middle of tokyo you don't
speak the language no at all at that
time no okay and now you're saying it's
the best decision in your life yeah so
what was the lowest moment you're like
holy [ __ ]
what did i just get myself into i'm
gonna go back home to america i can
clear this one up because it's a little
it's a rough it's a no it's a triumphant
victory but at the time it was a low so
i was dating this girl right
and a japanese girl yeah just dating her
and so
i told her i used to write this down
on my wall and i had a piece of paper in
my wallet that says you know one day i'm
gonna make ten thousand dollars a month
from the internet every single month net
profit oh wow and when i felt down i
would read it or when i would be
struggling to be like yeah [ __ ] i can't
pay my bills or some shit's going on it
would be on my walls so she had like
this come to jesus moment with me she's
like we need to talk she's like you have
to understand like this dream that you
have
of making this money on the internet
she's like you can't do it oh wow
yeah and she was like we lived in the
guest house at the time so it's like a
kind of like a
like a communal living situation like
there's a
community kitchen and there's like you
know community living room area and then
bedrooms and apartments upstairs right
mm-hmm
so she's like the other people in the
guest house like they think you're weird
and it's embarrassing for me why weird
wow because i wanted to make ten
thousand dollars a month from the
internet they thought you were weird
because you you had aspirations exactly
because they're all losers they were all
losers they were drinking partying like
you know just that this is in japan this
is in osaka
japan's a capitalist type of country
right yeah no no no it was uh it was a
mixed community people you know okay but
there's there's there's a certain type
what a [ __ ] weirdo wants to make
money and do something like that you're
a loser man yeah exactly smoke some weed
and play some video games exactly so
they had told me that and that really
hurt because i loved her at the time you
know and then i was like damn and then i
started to believe her tells like man
maybe she's right she's like you need to
get a regular job you need to think
about your future and keep in mind this
girl was [ __ ] absolutely this i was
still trying to like help her as like a
person you know help her out play it
safe bro don't take risks don't take
chances
so then after i dumped her i dated
another girl who was just like
blindly
loyal and supportive of me to like
like dude just like i could be like look
there's a body and we got it
the definition of a ride or die chase
yeah where's the show is that you well
it's usually we do the killing that's
the problem i can never find the person
who wants to
well
bury
it
a girl could dream yeah i know right so
don't incriminate yourself there monica
so that was 2015 2015 that happened and
then i had hit a a pretty low point i
had literally lost all my money i had
like 10 bucks
and then i dumped her i'd rebuild myself
back up lost it all again in 2018 but i
had the new girlfriend with me and
during the time when i lost all 2018 i
could feel the stress on her i could
feel the anxiety of her wanting me to
get the [ __ ] together and i knew i had
to my back was up against the wall by my
own pressure i didn't care if she's
gonna leave or whatever but i knew i
loved her and i knew it was stressing
her out but then finally i had my
breakthrough in 2019 big big
breakthrough and it all started with
you know burning the ships man and yeah
i think a lot of guys are
a lot of guys doubt themselves nowadays
that's what pisses me off because when i
see guys i see raw talent i'm like dude
you're like you know i tell these guys
i'm like dude you're good looking you're
just you don't meet any girls because
you stay at home and play video games
all day like why can't i meet girls so
if you like that clip click right here
to watch another or if you want to watch
the entire sauce cast click right here
[Music]